Buy now, pay later loans have seen astronomical growth in popularity.
You've probably seen these loans when shopping online.
They allow you to stretch out your purchases...
...over a few payments or installments.
Buy now, pay later loans may seem like a standard payment method,...
...but you are really taking on a new form of debt.
But before you check out,...
...here are some things to know about buy now, pay later loans.
1. Buy now, pay later loans typically don't include interest,...
...but you may be charged fees if you pay late.
2. Even if you return the item,...
...you may need to continue paying back your buy now, pay later loan...
...while the return is being processed.
You also may not have the same dispute protections...
...as you would with a credit card.
3. Buy now, pay later loans don't usually help your credit score,...
...but they can hurt you if you don't repay.
4. With buy now, pay later loans, you can get products fast,...
...but the debt can also build up quickly.
If you make multiple purchases on multiple schedules with multiple companies,...
...it may be hard to keep track of when payments are scheduled,...
...and if there is not enough money in your bank account to repay,...
...you could get hit with fees.